BRAD TEMPLETON: Hi, welcome,
this is Green at Google.
I'm Brad Templeton, and
today we have Olver
Kuttner from Edison2.
This company was the company
that won the X Prize for the
most efficient car that
was sponsored
by Progressive Insurance.
In this contest, people had to
make cars that could go better
than 100 miles per gallon.
They surprised everyone by
actually winning with a liquid
fuel-powered car, when the rules
had been aimed very much
for an electric car to win.
So Oliver has been committed
to making cars lighter and
more efficient and, is now
planning to use his prize
money to commercialize what they
built into a consumer car
that's the most efficient
out there.
So, Oliver.
OLIVER KUTTNER: Unfortunately,
before I used more than the
prize money.
We see a clear opportunity.
So basically, as you said,
the whole thing
began with the X Prize.
It wasn't looking for the most
efficient car, it was looking
for a car that is better than
100 miles per gallon and meets
a whole series of
other criteria.
It had to seat four people.
It had to be producible.
It had to have structures that,
with some modifications,
could meet all the
safety standards.
There were a lot of
other things.
It had to meet, if you decided
to burn fuel, emissions
standards, which turned
out to be probably the
single hardest thing.
Anyway, you preempted it.
We did win it.
What I did is I pulled together
a group of people
from motor sports, which is
something that I've been
interested in all my life, and
some aerodynamicists , and put
together a team.
Altogether, we were almost 100
people, about 20 core people.
The big "aha" moment was
the initial analysis.
I really believe that it's
time well spent to really
study stuff upfront
rather than guess
out and start working.
At the time, I didn't know much
about efficiency cars.
But racing, of course, is
efficiency because you have to
do everything in a fixed time,
and you don't want to burn
fuel, and you want to go
as fast as you can.
All those things are trade-offs
of efficiency.
And at the time, I remember the
president had pretty much
announced that we didn't have
an energy problem because
hydrogen fuel cells were coming,
and we were going to
have a hydrogen economy.
And so it was natural for us
to evaluate that first.
And in very short order, we
found problems, like a typical
gas station has a certain
number of PTU's that it
dispenses every day.
And that's roughly equivalent
to a single
tanker truck of gasoline.
If you wanted to fill the gas
station with hydrogen, you'd
have to bring in 22
tanker trucks.
The mechanics of it
became difficult.
Forget about the fact that it's
corrosive and you don't
know where the hydrogen
comes from.
The message in this was that
those in charge don't
necessarily know.
And this is a message that we've
been carrying all along.
Hybrids are the answer, I'm
going to get to that shortly,
and electric cars
is the current,
maybe crashing, story.
To me, losing was
not an option.
So we basically looked at
everything from the ground up.
And one of the first things we
did is we said, Well, how do
you measure fuel efficiency?
We looked at most of the main
standardization bodies, Japan,
Germany, USA.
And we found that the EPA is
probably the single best
institution.
Their test cycles are very
representative of what
actually happens.
And what you're looking at is
a graph of a city cycle.
It's a very prescribed
acceleration-braking situation.
And you can translate that
into energy spent as a
function of what it
is you're moving.
If it's heavier, you
need more energy.
So what is interesting to note
in here, is the blue lines are
energy spent.
The red line is energy available
for recovery, if you
could grab it all.
The green line is the cumulative
energy spent, and
the purple line is the
cumulative total energy
available for recovery.
We know that a very great
company, Toyota, has really
perfected the hybrid.
And on a good day, they
can capture 30% of
the recoverable energy.
That means 30 percent of the
purple line, which means the
potentially recoverable
energy is not so big.
So making a hybrid out of a
car doesn't get you to a
paradigm shift.
It is worth it.
And you can take that math
further, and you can look at
the weight of a car.
And the difference between the
green line below and the red
line is essentially the profit
from going hybrid.
And as you notice, as the cars
get heavier, going hybrid is
worth more and more, which
means a bus that's hybrid
makes a lot of sense.
But on the converse, as you get
down to 1,000 pounds, what
you gain from going hybrid
is minuscule.
As a matter of fact, it may be
so little that the hybrid gear
costs you more than
what you gain.
Now the other thing is, in
racing, you learn, in order to
win, first you must finish.
So if you add a hybrid here,
an electric drive, you have
two drive lines.
You have a much higher
likelihood
of mechanical failure.
And this was a one-time shot
at making money, so
we didn't want it.
So in the end result,
we decided we're
going to go with gasoline.
We decided to run E85, because
it gave us some advantages in
the way the emissions work.
And in miles per gallon
equivalent, we were able to
record 129 on the highway.
And final X Prize, I think we
got 102.5, but in the lab we
actually got 109 as a combined
cycle efficiency.
The car had an unprecedented
combination of low weight and
low aerodynamic drag.
We beat both our targets
in those numbers.
We did not beat our target in
the brake-specific fuel
consumption of the engine, but
all in all, it was enough.
And it was interesting because,
two years before we
ran X Prize, we predicted we
might get 110 miles per
gallon, and we actually
got 109.
The most significant number is
that our car can go 60 miles
an hour using 5.3 horsepower.
Now, the X Prize, some laugh
at it and see it
as a science project.
It clearly was a science
project, but you have to start
with a science project.
Google, outside you have cars
that have big things on top
and they look like a
science project.
But they're amazing cars and
they're clearly the future.
So we all start somewhere.
Since the X Prize, we've been
working on turning the science
project into a product that
consumers might want.
One of the things we did
recognize, even though we were
very skeptical about electric
cars initially, is that I
believe today that electric
cars are the mandatory,
inevitable future
of automobiles.
They make a lot of sense, they
are quite wonderful, there are
economic reasons to go that
way, but they also are the
only path to truly something
promising in the future.
In effect what we've done, by
creating a very light car,
we've solved the battery
problem.
Because when a car is very
light, it needs less energy,
which means you can carry a
smaller battery, which means
the battery costs less,
which means your
charge time is shorter.
To really put it in perspective,
this car, which
Brad saw some months ago, it
was here, can be charged at
any 110-volt outlet
in this room.
In six hours you get a full
charge for 100 miles.
If you want to drive this car
cross-country, like I did
recently, you can buy a two
kilowatt-hour Honda generator
that weighs 44 pounds, and put
it in the trunk, and plug in
an extension cord.
And you can pretty much drive
to the other side of the
country by putting gas in it.
What is quite stunning is this
very efficient car, using the
Honda generator, only gets
44 miles per gallon.
What this tells you is how you
lose, and lose, and lose.
It's the compounding
effect of losing.
This is what I was trying
to explain to you.
So this generator converts
gasoline into electricity.
The electricity goes into a
battery and comes back out.
And every time, you lose a
few percentage points.
By the time you're done, the
109-mile-per-gallon,
129-mile-per-gallon highway car
gets 44 miles per gallon.
There are a lot of lessons
that we've learned.
But I will say, electric
cars are the future.
They need to be.
Now, fuel price is not what's
going to change the world.
In Europe there are plenty of
people going Porsche Cayennes,
and gasoline is $10.
What will change the world is
that worldwide CO2 regulations
are now real, they are here.
In the US specific, this is a
graph that we prepared some
months ago.
These are the current
regulations starting in 2016
through 2025.
And the red dots are the
larger-volume cars sold in the
United States today.
The fleet averages must
be below the lines.
And the line allows a larger car
to have more CO2, that's
why it's a curved line.
But you can figure out very
quickly that the average is
way above the lines, and every
year the line drops.
Essentially, the industry's
in trouble.
The industry was counting
on electric cars being
larger-scale adopted.
They would be compliance
boosters.
Those cars are not selling
in numbers.
This is here, this
is real, and this
will change the industry.
At this point, in Detroit and
everywhere else in the world,
people are really starting
to wonder what to do.
Because, as opposed to every
other law before, the penalty
for not complying means you lose
your license to sell cars
in the United States.
This means that a company like
Land Rover, Jaguar, or
Mercedes could be faced with
not selling a single car.
And that is catastrophic.
So losing this is
not an option.
Essentially, they have the
same test that I had five
years ago with X Prize,
just bigger numbers.
And currently, everybody thinks
they're going to keep
doing business as usual, and
shave off a little here and
shave off a little there.
This is going to cost
billions of dollars.
If you do it correctly, you
might meet the standards, but
I do ask where do you
go from there.
Because you're now pulling out
all your weapons, and even if
you meet the standards with
all your weapons, at some
point, you're going to run
out of ammunition.
And all of these technologies
make a lot of sense.
But it goes to the old Einstein
saying, if you want
to come out with a different
outcome, you have to approach
the problem differently.
And I will drive this point
home with this slide.
In my opinion this
is the actual
efficiency limit of a car.
Essentially, cars are
architecturally all the same.
Today's cars are based
on a 1959 Mini.
They are front engine,
transverse, front-wheel drive
cars, for the most part.
They have MacPherson strut
suspensions, which in my
opinion define the
weight of a car.
And to me, the most efficient,
non-hybrid, gasoline-burning
car to-date is the 1992 General
Motors Ultralight,
with a carbon fiber chassis,
designed and built by the
winner of the first X
Prize, [INAUDIBLE].
It was a car built, cost no
object, and it was a car built
at the direction of General
Motors management, that was
supposed to get 100
miles per gallon.
It did not.
It got 88 miles per gallon
on the highway cycle.
The reason is, this
architecture
defines a glass ceiling.
You can improve direct injection
a little more, you
can do this a little more,
this a little more.
You're not going to
break the numbers.
As opposed to this, you take our
very simple car, 129 miles
per gallon in the same test,
with a steel frame, a new
system, and much lower
cost, because it's
architecturally different.
Industry hasn't lost the thought
that maybe they have
to change something.
These are some examples
of some tasters.
I think the industry is trying
to find out what
else they can sell.
I think the industry is
petrified, and they are
starting to try some things.
Volkswagen is, I
think, the most
forward-pushing, visible company.
I have a feeling that inside
Toyota, there is every bit as
much going on.
This Toyota that I photographed
in Geneva had a
very thin-walled steel chassis
tubing frame filled with foam.
It had a center spine.
Those are all things that
we have thought about,
made a lot of sense.
These guys have been around
the block on this, and
they're very good.
I don't know about the
rest of the industry.
I think there are some
big macro trends
that we'll also push.
One is transportation
electrification is going to
probably be driven most by the
fact that electric cars are
essentially coal burners.
And the green population doesn't
want to hear it, but
that's the truth, and eventually
hopefully they are
all solar powered.
But in the interim, they're
burning coal.
And coal is the cheapest BTU
on the planet, so they
actually have a cost advantage,
if you can reduce
the battery cost.
Congested cities are going
to drive some things.
I think your driverless cars
are in part about it.
And shared ownerships,
I think, are
going to only increase.
A big issue, in my opinion,
is job scarcity.
Requirements for local content
will increase.
Balance of trade, local content
requirement, these are
huge issues.
This is what has
killed Greece.
This is what is killing Spain,
Portugal, possibly France,
Belgium, and Italy.
The world cannot keep going
the shifting balance of
trades, and automobile
manufacturer is the single
biggest violator, besides oil.
If the United States just
fixed this automobile
importing problem and its fuel
importing problem, we would
have no balance of trade
issues whatsoever.
And Greece essentially had
no car manufacturing.
And that, in many ways, was the
root problem of why Greece
is where it is.
This is a problem that's
not going away.
And the way you solve it is you
start to make cars in your
more localized environments,
or parts for it.
And then, I think, there's a
huge opportunity, as I travel
around the world all the time.
There are all these low-cost bad
cars that are made by the
millions, that pollute like
crazy, that cost very little,
that are 1950s technology.
And our large companies have
no answers to compete with
these cars.
But these cars really should
be displaced by a
more elegant product.
And in our company, one of the
principles that we pursued, we
pursued all the X Prize
requirements, but we added one
requirement.
We said, listen, if we're going
to fail, we want to have
something that's worth
something.
So we said, we want
to design the
Volkswagen of the 21st century.
The car must be low-cost.
So here is we're going, and
I'll explain to you why
Edison2 is a completely
different company than any
other company.
It begins with a different
architectural approach.
The Very Light Car has
self-contained suspension
systems inside the
wheel itself.
This is important because the
real estate in the wheel is
not normally used in a car.
And by putting the suspension
inside the wheel, we drive it
down to a single connection
point, which then feeds four
main connection points
for the chassis.
Four connection points in
the chassis is much less
complicated than the 16
or 20 you would find
in a typical car.
And when you have these fewer
points, the geometry of the
chassis becomes easier, the
material content of the
chassis becomes easier,
therefore the
chassis becomes lighter.
And the whole thing is
a virtuous circle.
If the chassis is lighter, my
brakes are smaller, my engine
is smaller, my transmission
is smaller, and it goes
on and on and on.
This suspension is a product
that we believe has a lot of
value, and we're actually going
to launch a new company
that will only promote
the suspension.
Which, in our opinion, can take
about 200 pounds off any
existing car simply by
redirecting its chassis
requirements, and add a flat
floor, which gives you an
aerodynamic benefit and gives
you additional space under the
hood and in the trunk.
And additional space in a car is
at a premium today, because
cars are becoming
so complicated.
So we have high hopes for this
company, which should launch
in Quarter 2 , 2013.
But the other, we're still
dreaming to go to a car.
The other issue is, a light
car, to be safe.
A light car always loses the
battle of momentum in a crash.
And it's unacceptable that you
have a car in which you die in
an accident.
From motor sports, we know a lot
about high impact crashes,
and essentially, it's also a
change in architecture, it's a
change in approach.
We embrace the idea
of deflection.
In a normal car, you absorb
a crash, and you
engage the other car.
In our situation, we prefer
to jettison parts
and deflect the crash.
And this is really, brutally,
driven home in an actual crash
test following the IIHS 40%
Offset Crash Protocol in which
we recorded 21 g's.
To put it in perspective, this
is a crash I'm willing to sit
in the car with the seat belt,
not even an air bag.
21 g's is probably the lowest
ever recorded data for this.
Maybe a Plymouth Prowler,
because the Plymouth Prowler,
by accident, does
the same thing.
This comes out motor sports.
We all know about high-impact
crashes.
And the other part that we use
is, we substitute space for
our lack of mass.
If you look at this top view,
you see the flat places that
connect our wheels
with the body.
Those are purely structure,
there's no suspension in
there, because the suspension
is in the wheel.
So this structure is
designed to absorb.
So in a side-impact, in any
number of impacts, you have a
lot more absorptions space,
which you need to take care of
the added accelerations which
you have to face.
The third thing is that
we are all about cost.
And cost to me is what drives
it home in the end.
And here's just a simple
explanation.
I like station wagons, and
station wagons became
minivans, they became SUV's,
and I would argue they're
going to go back to being
station wagons.
And if you follow our
prescription, and you just
want a gas-burning station
wagon, 60 miles per gallon is
no problem whatsoever.
And essentially, over the
life of a car, you end
up with a free car.
And when you get the numbers so
different that you end up
with a free car, the customer
base exists, even if some
people look at it and raise
their eyebrows initially,
because money does talk.
And it gets really extreme when
you build an electric car
with a range extending engine.
The lowest energy cost of
operating car out there is
likely a Toyota Prius, which
can do this drive cycle for
about $15,000 in the US.
And we can do the same
drive cycle for 5500.
Same service, four
people my size.
So it shows you how brutal
the numbers get.
The architectural implications
are, we're all about cost, and
cost is about extreme parts
count production and reduction
in material.
I'll first talk about
material.
The average car in America
costs $6 a pound.
If you build a car out of
conventional materials, you
can keep those numbers.
An expensive car, let's say an
Audi with an aluminum chassis
might cost $20 a pound.
When you bring the car down
to 1,300 pounds with full
content, it stands to reason
that it's going
to cost less money.
How do we do it?
Parts count reduction.
We basically put most of the
complicated parts into a few
castings that are strategically
located, and
everything else is connections,
either deflecting
and absorbing, or, we don't let
anybody in because we're
going to keep your life.
Those are the two structures.
And if you insist that you want
to have a car that's a
box, you can use our
architecture, get the benefit
of the lightweight, and make
it look like a box.
Personally I don't like boxes.
I can see tremendous potential
for our designs.
You have additional wing areas,
I mean, they will
become high-performance cars
of unbelievable dimensions,
and it's just a lot of fun.
I also believe that the
extensive use of plastics is
essential, because you can fully
recycle the plastics,
and, once again, with molded
plastics, you can create
further parts count and
cost reduction.
Because a molded part
can take many, many
functions into one part.
And one thing that's interesting
here, this is one
of our development chassis, if
you look at it, that's a full
drive-line equipped chassis.
And look at the front bumper
and the rear bumper and you
see all this empty space.
What happens is, by making the
car so light, the drive line
becomes so small, the
car becomes entirely
space for the user.
These cars have big trunks,
even though
they don't look it.
They're actually big inside,
they can fit big people, but
they give you the space
where you need.
They don't give you the space
where you don't need it.
In a normal car, a third of your
car is just your engine
compartment, it gives you
no other service.
So it's interesting to note.
And ultimately, I can see a
scenario where you end up with
a plastic car with less than
30 parts, with less than 30
castings, and a few
other components.
And now you're in a whole
other dimension.
It's really a new product.
Our goal is to go to a new
distribution model.
The complicated parts will
be made centralized.
They will have some intensive
tooling, will cost some money.
And then, depending on where
the cars are made, they get
assembled more locally.
Essentially like flat packs, a
little bit like Ikea, except
the assembler is
a professional.
And that way, you can end up
with a car factory in Greece.
Because you're essentially
looking for a large warehouse,
and you ship in some parts.
And maybe the engines come from
China, let's take Chery,
for example, or Tata.
Both of them make 600-700
cc 2-cylinder engines.
They can be sourced for $1,000,
that's fuel injection
to catalyst.
They're nice aluminum engines,
and they can give you the
service that you get from
Volkswagen, Jetta, TDI.
And so you end up with the
parts coming in, and you
essentially have a large
glorified warehouse in which
you assemble the cars.
Edison2 is essentially
an R&D company.
We're not married to become a
Tesla, we're not married to
being anything.
We are married to being
successful.
We're married to our
product becoming a
large-volume situation.
At this point, we're raising
a little bit more money.
Edison2 is pretty much done.
We're going to have a suspension
company, which is a
sales company.
And in 2014, we intend to raise
the big money, and go to
our production of our car.
And by that time, we believe we
will have solved virtually
all the issues.
We have a car that's now maybe
seven weeks away from driving,
that is essentially the
efficiency that you've seen.
You've seen this car, except it
drives like a Toyota Camry.
It has the suspension travel,
it has all the functions of
what people want.
And it's a lot of work, but
we're getting there.
I believe, in looking at this
from an outsider, the big
problem in the car business is
that it is so money intensive,
and that it has kind
of killed itself.
Essentially the car business has
taken all the margin out.
And when you have no margin,
there's huge risk aversion and
unwillingness to change.
And up until a year ago, I was
unwilling to try to become a
car company, and at this
point our group's
moving in that direction.
Whether it becomes that we
become a division of somebody
or own car company remains
to be seen.
But we really think we can
deliver a full leap, and the
main reason we think so is
because we think the large
companies are going to be very,
very challenged, and
moving quickly.
Because there are so many
people, so many layers of
management, and because what
we're doing can so destabilize
them, because they have
such big investment.
So in this, I actually
see an opportunity.
Essentially, we are a
whole new product.
We're not a car, we're not a
motorcycle, we're a very light
car, but it's architecturally
completely different.
It will cost much different
money to operate.
And I think it opens a
whole new dimension.
I mean, here I'm sitting in the
middle of Google's place
and we're surrounded by all
kinds of high-tech companies.
I think that in the automobile
business, there will be a
re-scaled parts business,
because the idea of having
engines of 2,000 or 5,000 cc's
moving cars that move one
person is not sustainable, and
makes no sense at all.
The proportions are
just wrong.
And I think that there's
a great opportunity.
The other thing is, I was a car
dealer, I was a BMW dealer
for awhile.
And I find it stunning how the
car companies are trying to
have all the business.
And they've really taking the
joy out of owning a car.
They don't let you modify it,
they don't let you in it, they
don't let you understand it.
So in this thought that some
cars are going to want to be
shared-ownership cars, our
intention is to build very
simple cars, very simple base
cars, that are open to
modification.
So some people may buy them as
a fleet for shared ownership,
while other people may buy them,
and third parties may
make things to upgrade them,
essentially like an Android
platform with apps.
You customize your computer
all the time.
There's a huge business
around this.
There's not such a big business
around the car,
because the car from the people
who make the car is
essentially protected.
We're going to be open
to changing that.
I mentioned it earlier, there
is just a wrong proportion.
Moving 200-pound people, even
four people at 800 pounds with
4,000 pound boxes just
doesn't make sense.
It's not sustainable.
It's too much material, too much
energy, and want to point
out one example.
A Very Light Car chassis today
weighs less than 100 pounds.
It's aluminum, part of it's
cast, part of it's stamped.
It's riveted and
glued together.
That 100 pounds of aluminum
is the same 100 pounds of
aluminum you save by cutting
your engine size in half.
Sitting here at Google, I wonder
about your driverless
cars, and I can see a future
where everybody has a
driverless car, where smaller
cars have small batteries, and
have relatively short range.
Have some contactless charging
on a highway, and become very
affordable because they're
so simple.
And I can actually see a
driverless small car
obsoleting public transport.
Because you now have individual
mobility, with the
efficiency of public transport,
or better.
And because your Google systems,
you can really pack
them into road systems, and
really solve some of these
issues that seem almost
unsolvable the big, congested
traffic situations, etc.
So in a way, it's a very
exciting time, and it's a lot
of dots that have
be connected.
Here's a bit of a brochure thing
that we're working on.
On the final page, you see a
little bit where we're going.
This will be the first car we
will actually offer, or what
we think we will offer.
And it's a hybrid car, it can
run on two different modes--
on a gasoline mode and
an electric mode.
And you read the data, it's
a pretty peppy car.
Somebody who has a 3 Series BMW
isn't going to be sorry
about switching to this car.
But it's a stunning
performance/efficiency ratio.
And because of the low parts
count, and the low mass, we
think we can deliver it at
a whole new price value.
Thank you very much.